[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: A Google search, a
YouTube video, a connected Nest
device, and hundreds
of Google Cloud
services all give you a response
in a fraction of a second.
But what really happens when you
click Search, send a request,
or say, OK, Google.
Well, your message travels
over the public internet
and into Google's
global fiber network.
Millions of these requests,
or packets of data,
travel through miles
of cable over land
and under sea, converging
at one of the many data
centers we operate
all over the world.
But besides delivering
quick results back to you,
what exactly is a data center?
A data center is a building
with powerful computers used
to run a company's services.
It's where information is
processed and made available.
Data is stored, managed,
and disseminated
across these computers.
And network infrastructure
is installed
to support web apps, databases,
virtual machines, and more.
Often, organizations start
with their own modest buildings
made up of a few
server racks, which
requires maintaining these
systems, paying for cooling,
and handling increasing demand.
So many companies look
to a cloud services
provider like Google Cloud.
These providers'
data centers have
evolved into large campuses
of multiple buildings.
Hyperscale data centers,
made up of tens of thousands
of servers, process big data,
support cloud computing,
and serve billions
of users for services
like Chrome, Maps, Gmail,
Search, and Google Cloud.
In the cloud world,
companies and users
can benefit from this scale
because of a special thing
called multitenancy.
This means customers can share
the resources of each server
in a data center, like tenants
sharing common resources
of an apartment building.
Each tenant's cloud systems
are isolated and invisible
to other tenants.
This means higher compute
processing and storage,
a more efficient use of data
center resources, and a much
lower cost than if you
managed your own servers.
Google Cloud customers can even
deploy resources in regions
across the world, which
are enterprise data center
locations with
three or more zones.
Zones are deployment areas that map to clusters of machines
with distinct physical infrastructure.
Companies can deploy workloads
across multiple zones
to help protect against
unexpected failures, something
you can't always get with a
single, private data center.
It takes a right mix of energy,
cooling, and people to keep
a data center up and running.
But it's a technical
feat Google's managed
to pull off to optimize for
efficiency, scale, and cost.
More on that next time on
"Discovering Data Centers."
[MUSIC PLAYING]